salvi
buongiorno salve mi appoggio qua ok che
faccio la intro grazie gentile questi
ragazzi perché sono video sono famiglie
oggi siamo dati su bird simulator che è
uscito gioco completo quanto potete
vedere merita allora è la cosa bella del
gioco completo e che è online ce l'hanno
fatta sul gioco online adesso mi
spiegate che cosa stradi chiami
significa questo gioco c'è un corvo che
c'è un corpo che prende un altro corpo
mi vuoi spiegare come fai
come fai a far danno agli altri o e
diventando etv call of duty
niente tu puoi sparare agli altri corpi
attenzione gli è stata una ucciso
no non ho ucciso scherzava ma ucciso lui
pezzente schifoso poi anche migliorare
il grip rotello c'è il portogallo sia
giusto cioè il personaggio tu puoi anche
diventare un piccione serio però si
sbloccano con i soldi
e i soldi si fanno cioè vede che adesso
invece nato si dice in alto la scritta
monete ecco se tu aumenti le monete puoi
comprarti gli altri uccelli vedo che il
piccione più potente costa 15 mila
quindi non so come fate ad arrivare a 15
mila però vedo che c'è stato che sta
continuando ad ammazzarmi quindi sono
sicuro che iniziano da lui
ok dovrebbe andare quel pezzetto che mi
sono fatto male dopo ti faccio mai la
solo quando cago come è possibile dove
eccolo eccolo sta arrivando
brutto schifoso vieni qua prodotto
presente ma lettura che mira che c'è un
abate mira perché iniqua brutto
maledetto b o la orca vacca è il collo
più ti degli uccelli uccello of duty
l'hack è male come si iscriva li
proietta e vab era impossibile quello
giocato a fornite tutta la viva cos'è ai
ragazzi comunque mi ha sorpreso il fatto
che ci fossero online
noi ci avete nella demo che ho provato
un po di tempo fa c'è un mesetto fa non
c'erano online
beh vedo che ben speso comunque hanno
investito bene i loro soldi per il
questo gioco merica tra questo e del
training non so guarda poi che stanno
servono brutto sembrava un modo per far
guidando e tipo non lo so ci devo
prenderla gente c'è un modo porca vacca
ci siamo ci siano stavolta la villa c'è
la minaccia eccolo lo uccido stavolta
lucido l'ho ucciso 200 monete perfetto
hyatt
se mi mettessi a fare una partita online
serie riuscire a sbloccarmi il piccione
volo potente prova le e questo si può
fare il suo gioco a parte ammazzare gli
altri posso prendere questa è una
baguette come ha fatto prima prenda la
lo zio non ho idea di quale sia il tas a
ok il tasto è sui premi e per mangiare
not press action
ok dai ball a cosa succede
la demo era molto meno pagata di sta
cosa già ragazzi incredibile digiuno c'è
una gara nata la cos'è una granata alla
bomba come file avrà una botta ammazzo
di nuovo altri 200 punti grazie
c'è una granata e gigantesca tra l'altro
posso prenderla si prendono ieri nostro
questi prendono gli oggetti c'è un menu
di comandi ma veramente povero l'ho
preso cielo ciò una bomba o una bomba
aspetta aspetta che questa cosa lanciamo
seria è detta dove un piccione dame teli
che cammina lì che cammina mi hai
ammazzato due volte occhio che investono
ora meriti di morire bomba
button ok tutto a posto tutto bene ma
ora che scappa scappa dove scappi che
c'è un edificio a frate madonna cioè un
genocidio di un dvd piccioni va bene
comunque nello shop che compra altri
piccioni voglio capire chi è che si
sparò sbatte costa 10 euro sto gioco 10
non ne vale uno non ne vale neanche
urlava com'è possibile
lo facevo meglio come fa stima di aver
accettato una cagata così nel suo
repertorio mi spiegate che guarda
orribile gioco più brutto dell'anno in
troll
non ho mai giocato niente di più
schifoso tutta la mia vita incredibile e
quindi ragazzi non potevamo fare
altrimenti che per i giornali sui blog
simulator dopo 60 anni allora è no non è
vero l'ho rifatto abbastanza
recentemente ma mancava quest'app allora
ho riletto tutto tranne questa parte qua
e sfruttiamo al fatto che stavamo
facendo
baird simulator che non è abbastanza a
lungo per farci video purtroppo perché
per dieci è l'antica ho fatto dei giochi
nella mia vita che sono costati 90
centesimi che sono durati per tre video
e ci sono giochi che costa 10 euro che
non ne basta neanche mezzo tipo voli
primo video ottimo ma va tutto bene in
realtà ragazzi perché mi mancava questa
parte di colazione c'è la voglia fatta
ma mi mancava la di giocare da un botto
è nulla di gioco va bene scusate amici
può cavalcare sta roba
non ho capito come l'ho presa però l'ho
presa lecca un over bike no scusate i
ragazzi volevo fare un discorso
bellissima farei
ricordo visto gioco i ragazzi ci ha
giocato una trentina di ore il che è
imbarazzante se ci pensate però finito
non so bene i comandi a con l'abi si
materializzano le over bike va bene vado
in colonia giorno salve sono una capra
ho bisogno di capire dove devo andare
non mi ricordo assolutamente come fatto
tutto sto ambientazione incredibile ci
avevo fatto un episodio mi pare solo uno
peccato perché la meriterebbe un sacco
va bene comunque ragazzi ho sollevato
c'è scritto la sopra 19mila dollari
perché tu in questa non so per quale
motivo ma in nello spazio dei vip in
qualche modo fare soldi non sono sicuro
della motivazione però devi fare soldi
ma perché col over bike e posso andare
ovunque fare quello che voglio però ok e
non ho ben capito se ce l'ho perché ci
avevo giocato o se la danno di base a
tutti quanti però va bene mi fa piacere
che c'è anche la minima ma posso
cortesemente provare a fare grazie
siccome si guida le capacità non mi
scusi la rr grazie si guida
c'è un tasto da premere per no come
seguito ci sono ci sono molto bene tutto
a posto
ce l'ho fatta non era così difficile
ragazzi perfetto meraviglioso saperlo
prima è un po scomodo da guidare e
sinceramente però non è male secondo me
se vinse guidarlo
quando stai andando fuori stando fuori
dovresti andare tornare dentro torna
dentro ragazzi sto finendo
nell'iperspazio spero che questo
problema
beh cosa vedo c'è della roba è
raggiungibile nello spazio la roba mi sa
che non ero arrivato fino qua e rumore
iena cagata ma mi sa che fino qua non
c'era arrivato il che mi sorprende per
questo gioco messo aveva scoperto tutto
evidentemente no tieni premuto r per
essere buongiorno è soltanto all'inizio
va bene ma non voglio parlarci questo
tizio mani avanti
e stato difficile ma siamo ritornati qua
ragazzi let's go arrivo arrivo ha
rivolto lo prendo lo prendo ragazzi
tranquilli che lo prendo e me lo sento
di qualche modo per mi sembra che vi
ricordate tutti story per l'aiuto
quando vi segue la macchinina nelle gare
stessa cosa è però lo prenderò mai di
guado tagliare porco demoni un edificio
in mezzo non tagliare dell'edificio vai
taglia riesco a intercettarla moto se ti
apri solo se ti apri ok c'è un recinto
sono entrato
non so cosa ci sia qua dentro l'arena
degli hunger games
c'è un codice per le ceste cosa di star
wars c'è un codice 40 watt e una prova
scandalizzato vediamo cosa succede
ma curiosissimo sono sono delle
coordinate degli stati uniti c'è che
strana sta cosa che permette le
coordinate finiscono nel montana ma
veramente di questo posto c'è anche una
scritta c'è scritto gesù ti ama
bellissimo cosa che si scoprono giocando
a golf simulator ragazzi io comunque c'è
tutto il giorno per registrare nov ha
deciso di iniziare verso sera perché
comunque la sera sono più tranquillo
rilassato indovinati quando i miei
vicini deciderli trapanare sino muro ma
chi se ne frega basta che ci divertiamo
cosa sta roba space training basta
miglior agazzi ste cose non me le
ricordo come quello giuro che non mi
ricordo di aver mai provato sta roba
you have the jay come dg che you take
che ne so se proviamo del più cascini
non l'aveva in rosa abbiamo vela sono
morto tutto bene
madonna raga benissimo un vero eroe la
tua magnificenza abbagliando il tema
cosa ho fatto sbloccato qualcosa con 20k
sbloccato sbloccato questa cosa con
20.000 dollari gemo deve farci altri 20
pisoni sull'ultimo dei tordi cose che
non ho mai visto mai come ho fatto a non
farlo ma saperlo prima raga ma che pirla
la penalità che sta prendendo la
rincorsa riesco ad arrivare esattamente
lì si perfetto ci siamo guida signori
tutto bene
bellissimo a posto ho capito devo
muovere le bravo mio dio
ok quell'astronave che ho sbloccato è
stata quello che è perfetto ci siamo mi
sa che ma le uova che sta sparando ai a
ma che mi spara alla donna ma chi è che
mi ha sparato io vedo nessuna vista
sparandosi maglia che il dolore forte
scampo alla svelta vedremo sono gli è
stato ma che vista spara laddove erano
il giorno che mi stavo girando ma non le
vedevo kg premuto ernie per essere ok
signori io sono cotto pero bello perché
stiamo facendo ma scusate sì
[Musica]
in qualche modo ho molte più domande
adesso
[Musica]